[Music]
we are going to move to our next speaker
and that is Eric who's gonna be talking
about natural metabolic ecosystems
alright thanks can you guys hear me okay
all right yeah I mean ecologists I want
to talk a little bit about the longevity
of nature so I see nature as this you
know a billion years of open-source R&D
on how to build a robust system I've
spent a lot of time and ecosystems
ranging from the marine environment to
Alpine ecosystems which is my new more
recent passion and and at the root of
all ecosystems is metabolism everything
needs to eat something and so when you
add that up it creates a food web which
is really just a network of energetic
flows where each species biomass
increases as it consumes and it
decreases as it gets consumed and these
are highly nonlinear systems so they're
they're not analytically tractable in
these models they're all run by
metabolism and biological constraints
and they are chaotic but very persistent
and incredibly resilient to knocking
them with a hammer and they bounce back
so so in ecology there was so I echo
systems are these icons of complexity
Darwin called him the entangled bank
where species are so interdependent and
connected with dependent on one another
and for a long time ecologists had this
assumption that it was that complexity
of nature that gave it its resilience
the complexity begets stability and in
1972 Bob May Robert may published this
landmark paper questioning that
assumption and he he demonstrated that
if he randomly hook up an ecosystem it
is inherently unstable and that they
their their tendency is to crash and he
basically stimulated with this paper
decades of work on answering this
question which is
what are the devious strategies by which
complex ecosystems don't crash so rather
than seeing the fact that since seeing
complexity being the source of
resilience of ecosystems people realized
that equals were resilient despite their
complexity and so there was decades of
work done on that and that's something
that's been really interesting to me is
just flipping it on his head so people
started gathering data on what are those
systems look like I'm an empiricist and
so I really love getting data to get the
big picture of you this is a colleague
of mine who created one of the first
really comprehensive food webs in the
early 90s of Little Rock Lake in
Wisconsin where every ball is a species
and they're linked by who eats home and
then algorithm sort them to find this
loose hierarchy of nature there there is
no such thing as a food chain it's a
food web and and there is a hierarchy
it's a loose hierarchy because things
feed at multiple levels but you can
uncover that pattern through with some
algorithms and as we started getting
data on more systems real empirical data
we look like they have patterning to
them and if you know from a rainforest
to a stream to a lake the burgess shale
is a fossil food web from 500 million
years ago from the burgess shale that my
colleague and friend Jessica Jennifer
done at the Santa Fe Institute put
together with a paleontologist and it
doesn't just with the naked eye we see
there's pattern if we compare those
things to randomly generated webs we
really see that food webs in nature are
non-random the architecture is very
non-random and and if you look at the
statistical properties of the structural
properties of them the burgess shale web
is very similar to contemporary webs
that that structure that architecture
has been persisted through time 500
million years which is really remarkable
so we read things like this like in
school when John Muir when we try to
pick out anything by itself we find it
hitched to everything else in the
universe and it's a wonderful poetic
statement and it makes us learn that
everything is connected but actually
this isn't true everything is not
equally connected and everything is not
randomly connected and it's that
non-randomness which is information
about what makes complex systems
persistence be rode
okay and I so I want to dive into just
four examples of this that that
non-random the information that's in
that non-randomness two of them are
structural and two of them are more
about process rates and how their
patterns are in nature so in the
structural sense going back to these
images one thing that food webs tend to
have is that there's they're short and
fat and they they have a wide base at
the bottom and a narrower top and the
abundance of those pieces at the bottom
is greater and they're more rare at the
top and and there's just isn't a counter
example of this there are with all these
things exceptions exceptions to the rule
but Mono Lake is an ecosystem that is
known for being very fragile and if you
in that ecosystem there are millions of
birds from hundreds of species that
migrate through the Eastern Sierra this
is just east of the east entrance of
Yosemite that stopped to feed on their
migration north and south and and they
literally if you go in the spring on the
shores of Mono Lake the birds literally
just run with their mouths open filling
their mouths with brine flies it's it's
really impressive to watch how much they
fatten up on food there but that system
is fragile this is what it looks like at
the base of it are two species of prime
to primary producers there's a pelagic
one floating in the water column there's
one benthic algae that's on the bottom
where there's light on the shoreline and
then there are brine shrimp that feed on
the pelagic algae there's brine fly
larvae that feed on the benthic algae
and then stacked on top of that is
hundreds of species of birds water birds
that eat brine shrimp shorebirds edie
brine flies and then birds that eat
birds and this is really this is a house
of cards is it looks like it once you
stack it up and indeed this ecosystem
was extremely vulnerable to diversion of
water by Los Angeles fresh water into
the aqueduct that raises salinity lake
change the abundance of brine shrimp and
brine fly birds are declining it also
happens to be a highly controllable
system there's a couple control points
so just by putting fresh water back in
it bounced back which is amazing and and
while Mono Lake has been around for
seven or thousand years it's unclear how
long this ecosystem has been there in
the state but
but it's it's an exception of the rule
but it's also known as being fragile it
doesn't have a wide bottom so that's the
first devious strategy is that robust
natural ecosystems tend to be short and
fat and some of the shortness comes also
from Omni every that that you don't have
long food chains you have usually top
predators also eat things lower down on
the food chain and that that effectively
shortens that the height of the
ecosystem let me give you a second
example
that's structural and this comes from
some work that I did recently one last
last decade actually with some
colleagues in Chile looking at this
Chilean ecosystem on the coast of Chile
and we compiled for the first time every
known interaction between all the
species that live on the rocky shores
and the tide pools and everything
because there was a long history of
research there and that included all of
the metabolic interactions who eats who
but also all of the non metabolic
interactions who helps him who competes
with whom and what way all that kind of
stuff it's and and we we published this
just a few years ago network structure
beyond food webs and it's to our
knowledge the most comprehensive
ecological network that takes into
account all of the known metabolic and
non metabolic interactions in a full
ecosystem and then we did some modeling
and and all that to understand its
resilience and persistence sorry you
wanted that and so what's really great
about these marine systems is that for
in a small area there's a wide diversity
of species that is go back ok a wide
diversity of species that's deep
diversity that every branch of life is
represented there it's not a thousand
flavors of beetles it's very different
life forms from tunicates to algae to
sponges to anemones to brachiopods to
crabs it's really diverse life forms and
and so it's a really interesting system
to understand diversity of interactions
this is what it looks like where every
dot is a species and they're linked in
various ways the blue lines are
metabolic links who eats whom the grey
lines are competitive links who competes
with whom for example nudging each other
off the rock for space etc
and then the the reddish pink lines are
who helps him facilitation links and
those links are non randomly organized
both the metabolic and non metabolic and
there's a couple hidden structures that
we were able to find in them one is that
they sort themselves out into modules or
compartments so here you can see that
they're these colors are groups with
species that tend to interact more with
one another than with the rest of the
community just like a social clique and
those compartments tend to prevent
crashes from one place spreading widely
to other places and that's a common
thing we see in other kinds of food webs
is is compartmentalization of the webs
okay and then there's another hidden
structure well this is groups of species
that tend to interact more with one
another this pattern is groups of
species that tend to interact in similar
ways with the same other species so each
color is they're not species they
interact with one another they're
species that are similar that they
interact in similar ways with the same
other species so every color is a group
of species that are exchangeable in a
way in terms of their function and this
creates redundancy in the web where one
of those species could go extinct and
the functional role is replaced by the
other species it also what it does is it
collapses the complexity of the system
from hundreds of species to tens of
functional species that are similar to
one another and that are you know I
don't want to say replaceable but you
know they call it functionally redundant
so that redundancy makes a big
difference so we see this in a lot of
other ecosystems and in pollination
networks and seed dispersal networks
that that a lot of robust systems tend
to be compartmentalized and also have
redundancy built into them and a
functional redundancy okay so now I want
to move on to two examples that are more
about not about structure so much is
about process rates and they boil down
to body size so one empirical
observation is that in natural systems
big things tend to eat smaller things
and there are we can always think of a
lot of exceptions with pests and
parasites in etc but we my colleagues
and I about a decade ago
child but over a tens of thousands of
examples a data set of known consumer
prey relationships where we had body
size information and this holds across
terrestrial marine and freshwater
ecosystems that on average the central
tendency is for consumers to be on
average that say 10 times larger than
their prey is a common thing with a
spread and and this has really important
implications for process rates the
reason for that is that as organisms get
bigger so on the x axis here is body
mass the y axis is their metabolic rate
metabolic rate goes up as you get bigger
but it's not a one-to-one relationship
so so as you double in size your
metabolic rate doesn't double it goes up
to the 3/4 power it's less than a
one-to-one line so your mass specific
metabolic rate your metabolic rate per
unit mass goes down and and and that
makes it that larger organisms have
slower process rates than smaller
organisms and there's a whole theory of
metabolic ecology looking at how this
particular constraint plays out in in
the abundance distributions of species
all over Earth and it's it's you call
these a very messy science where there's
a lot of noise and the data this is one
of the few areas in ecology where the
theory that the lines are super tight
and there's not a lot of Claddagh points
of the line through it they're really
tight relationships that are driven by
these constraints on metabolism and
there's theories about how that is based
on the fractal nature of how energy is
distributed in the body it's really
interesting Theory metabolic Theory of
ecology but in for food webs what's
interesting is that at the same time
big things tend to eat little things and
some of that is morphological
constraints like their their mouth size
is only so big so they can't eat things
bigger than etc that the patterning in
food webs means that as you move from
the bottom of the web at the top you
tend to get bigger and bigger organisms
and that means that as you go from the
bottom the top the process rates slow
down and if you run models the other way
around like with with with parasites and
diseases they blow up really quickly
they're really volatile if you have
little things eating big things but if
you have big things eating little things
it's it's a lot
more stable it's an inherently
stabilizing thing and the other thing
that happens is that for omnivores ones
that eat across multiple trophic levels
they tend to prefer their lower trophic
level level prey so they more than ergy
comes from lower down on the food chain
and and then that also is a very
stabilizing factor okay so they eat
they'll eat let's say if you have a
spread in your diet the smaller things
tend to be more abundant and so just
optimal foraging means that they tend to
eat more lower on the food chain and you
see that if you do stable isotope
analysis of their guts that that more
the energy is coming from lower down in
the chain so that's a very common thing
and again that shrinks the height of a
lot of food webs because long skinny
webs are very unstable are very fragile
so wide fat webs or short fat webs are
more stable and the emergent property of
that is when you add it all up and you
run the models and even in nature and
what you observe is that many
interactions become weak manipulation
and a few are strong so most of the
links so this is actually an empirical
web from from the Caribbean or marine
food web by jordi Escalante who's a
friend and colleague and and all the
links are energy flows between the
species who are all just laid out in a
circle and a few of them are really
strong a lot of biomass flowing and most
of them are very weak and that actually
is an emergent property of the
patterning of how body size is in food
webs and the constraints of body size on
metabolism and then it and then this
comes out and when we run simulations
same thing we get this as an emergent
pattern of nature and and the
consequence of this is that long chains
of strong interactions long loops are
are generally weak because all it takes
is one weak link to break a chain of
interactions and there's a lot of work
on this that's been done but you know
while ago where weak links in long loops
and food webs are very stabilizing as it
just prevents these big feedback of
strong feedback loops from cycling and
causing volatility weak links and long
loops we also observe this when we did
simulations of thousands of ecosystems
Bay
on metabolic rules that that are
constrained to be biologically plausible
and we what we did was we did these
knockout experiments with thousands of
ecosystems and hundreds of thousands of
feet of relationships and if we would
knock out a species and then see how
everybody else changed and for every one
of those relationships we know is it one
degree away two hops away three hops
away four hops away the the y-axis is
the strength of that response either a
positive response or a negative response
and then the x axis is how many hops
away was a species we were observing and
you can see there's a lot hovered around
zero which is a lot of interactions are
weak and inconsequential but that the
maximum responses are strong one hop
away and they dampen very quickly with
distance so again you hit it with a
hammer
it doesn't propagate far and this is a
very important property of robustness of
ecosystems so what that means is that
this quote is just wrong if every time
we swatted a fly or killed a mosquito it
propagated strongly far and wide all
these things would crash because every
single day things are little
disturbances are happening and they
don't crash and the reason for that is
because because perturbations don't
travel far and and that is a it's not a
that is a an emergent property of a lot
of other things that have to do with the
patterning of interactions so a last one
I want to share that surround process
rates has to do with with dead stuff in
nature so if we look at okay so what
sorry this was just summary though on
big things - need small things the
patterning of that resume means that
disturbances don't travel very far so
the final one is around dead stuff and
one of the things that I only learned
this some later in my career by
collaborating with a microbial ecologist
that only 10% of the biomass of plants
and trusts or ecosystems is actually
consumed when it's alive 90% of it is
consumed and processed and metabolized
when it's dead so this whole
decomposition equation is 90% of
your plant biomass is processed one dead
and what that means is it has a very
different process rate so what it means
is that um every species in an ecosystem
is is two degrees from dead stuff these
are two lakes where every dot is a
species and they're linked by who eats
whom the circled one in red is detritus
or just or dead stuff basically of leaf
matter etc that's broken down and what's
highlighted are all the species that are
two hops away from dead stuff which is
ninety percent of the web and this is
throughout all the webs we looked at
over ninety percent of the species are
only two hops away from dead stuff that
means that every consumer resource
interaction is coupling green energy
channels and brown ones and if you look
across cities so there's a predator
that's herbivores that are eating plants
and ones that are eating detritivores
are eating dead stuff there's two energy
channels a slow one which is dead stuff
and a fast one the green energy Channel
is faster and so consumers are coupling
like a diverse portfolio fast and
volatile channels that are more
productive and lower productivity but
slower channels and this again has a
stabilizing effect by coupling
oscillators that are not in sync is a
very stabilizing factor so that's the
fourth devious strategy by which Nature
doesn't crash is slow and fester energy
channels through dead stuff are coupled
on different so there's different
timescales tends to be state stabilizing
and just to recap we started for many
years in ecology with and this is still
common assumption based on what would
they teach in school is that complexity
begets stability
instead he colleges have been working
for decades on the reverse of this which
is why don't complex system ecosystems
crash because by default if they're
randomly connected and equally connected
they would and so some of the devious
strategies include natural ecosystems
that are robust tend to be short and fat
they're compartmentalized and have
redundancy we see this again and again
big things tend to eat little things
slow process rates are stacked on top of
fast process rates and those consumers
are coupling brown and green energy
channels which also have very different
process rates that are out of sync with
each other and the result of that is
that you end up with this emergent
pattern of most of the relationships are
kind of weak and only a few are strong
and that means that if you hit it with a
hammer disturbances don't propagate very
far they don't hop very far and long
strong chains of interactions are rare
so the examples that we learn of these
trophic cascades that are really
impressive of you know this effects that
which affects that which affects those
actually are very rare in in real
systems but they capture our attention
because they're really they're really
fascinating so um the recurring theme on
all this is that yes everything is
connected but everything is not equally
connected
nor is it randomly connected and it's
really that non randomness of the
patterning of the architecture of nature
that is where this library of
information about longevity exists so
that's all I had to share with you thank
you
[Applause]
[Music]
you